[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta slonka guten Abend bei
seinem Besuch heute in Israel warnte
Bundeskanzler Scholz erneut vor einem
Flächenbrand da wusste er noch nicht
welche Bilder später am Abend aus Gaza
kommen würden Bilder genau die genau
diese Furcht verstärken und die auch das
grundsätzliche Dilemma zeigen vor dem
Israel in diesem Krieg steht bei einem
Raketeneinschlag auf ein Krankenhaus in
gazastadt soll es hunderte Tote gegeben
haben Peter Bömer
berichtet am Abend diese Bilder aus dem
Gazastreifen ein Krankenhaus in
gazerstadt soll nach Angaben des Hamas
Gesundheitsministeriums von einem
israelischen Luftschlag getroffen worden
sein hunderte Menschen sein getötet oder
verletzt worden hieß es keine
Bestätigung vom israelischen Militär ein
Sprecher sagte man werde sehr genau
prüfen was dort geschehen sei die Hamas
öffnete gestern eine neue andere Front
des Krieges sie veröffentlichte ein
Video ind dem eine junge Geisel zu sehen
ist ihr verletzter Arm wird offenbar in
einem Krankenhaus im gaserastreifen
behandelt das ZDF zeigt daraus nur
Standbilder die junge Frau sagt ich bin
21 Jahre alt und komme aus schoham holt
mich hier bitte so schnell wie
die Mutter der jungen Frau am Vormittag
vor der
Presse ich bitte die Welt darum mir mein
Baby
zurückzubringen man sieht dass sie unter
Schock
steht dass sie Schmerzen
hat ich sehe dass sie Dinge sagt die ihr
vorgesagt
werden aber ich sehe auch dass sie
stabil das Video aufgenommen wurde die
israelische Armee teilte heute
mit ich möchte es ganz klar sagen das
ist psychologischer Terror der
Hamas in diesem Video versucht die Hamas
sich als humane Organisation
darzustellen aber sie ist eine brutale
und mörderische Organisation die
verantwortlich ist für den Tod von
Kindern Frauen und älteren
Menschen die israelische Armee setzte
die Bombenangriffe auf Ziele im
Gazastreifen fort ein weiterer hoher
Hamas Kommandeur soll dabei getötet
se Bilder von einem anderen Angriff
zeigen wie Helfer Tote und Verletzte aus
den Trümmern ziehen und wegtragen das
Leid der Menschen die hier
[Applaus]
wohnen wir saßen hier und haben gebacken
wir haben nichts gemacht die Leute sind
hungrig weil wir nicht mal Strom haben
oder Wasser ich schwöre wir haben nur
gebacken und plötzlich dieser Luftschlag
über uns und dann war plötzlich alles
dunkel in Raffa an der Grenze zwischen
Ägypten und dem gaz weiterhin Stillstand
endlos Schlangen warten LKWs mit
Hilfsgütern Nahrung Medizin Technik aber
niemand kommt aus dem gaserstreifen
hinaus kein Lastwagen hinein kann sein
dass wir hier sogar mehr als genug haben
für unsere Leute in Gaza Nahrungsmittel
Käse Milch Produkte Gemüse Medikamente
und medizinische
Geräte mehr als genug sagt er jenseits
der Grenze dringend erwartet aber es
kommt bisher nichts
hinein das wollen wir noch weiter
vertiefen mit unseren Korrespondenten in
Tel Aviv und in Kairo zunächst nach
telaviv zu Michael beberunge Michael
hast du jetzt noch aktuelle
Informationen am Abend zu dem Beschuss
oder zu dem Raketeneinschlag auf dieses
Krankenhaus in
gazastadt ja es gab bisher eigentlich
nur Spekulationen und jetzt vor ganz
wenigen Minuten eine Meldung der
israelischen Armee die ganz klar sich
festlegt und sagt eine Rakete des Jihad
hat dieses Krankenhaus aus getroffen es
war nicht die israelische Luftwaffe
überprüfen können wir das nicht
letztendlich zeigt das in welch
furchtbare Situation die Bevölkerung in
Gaza ist n kommt morgen der US-Präsident
nach Israel diese Ereignisse jetzt rund
um dieses Krankenhaus in wie weit werden
die seine diplomatischen Bemühungen
erschweren ja das zeigt wie schwierig
ist diese diplomatischen Bemühungen zu
einem Erfolg zu führen denn genau das
war das Ziel einen humanitären Korridor
humanitäre Lieferungen
einzurichten sichere Plätze für die
Zivilbevölkerung zu schaffen und nachdem
der Außenminister das gestern Nacht
verkündet hat gibt es überhaupt keine
Fortschritte sondern im Gegenteil mehr
Bombardements mehr Tote Joe Biden will
gleichzeitig auch Israel ganz klar einen
solidaritätsbesuch abstatten er sagt es
gebe das Recht und sogar die Pflicht
Israels seine Bevölkerung zu zu
verteidigen und weitere Attacken wie am
7 Oktober solche Terrorattacken
abzuwehren gleichzeitig will er
Fortschritte in der geiselfrage
erreichen und das sind ja alles sich
widersprechende Ziele die sehr sehr
schwierig nur erreicht werden können
also der Besuch von Joe Biden steht
erstmal um kein auf unter keinem guten
Stern es wird sehr schwierig sein dass
er morgen seinen Besuch hier erfolgreich
beendet er wird dann ja auch
weiterreisen geplant ist auch nach Kairo
zu reisen goline atil
ist dort jetzt aus Kairo uns
zugeschaltet golin zuvor warst du im im
Libanon bist heute erst wieder
zurückgekommen nach Ägypten wir sehen
jetzt die Reaktionen am Abend auf diese
Ereignisse in Gaza
aus das schlägt hier hohe Wellen sehr
viel Empörung sehr viel Entrüstung in
den arabischen Medien in der vergangenen
Stunde ist immer wieder von einer
Eskalation die Rede von einem Wendepunkt
die Rede es gibt eine ganze Reihe von
Ländern die sich gemeldet haben ar Oman
Libanon jeemen Jordanien Ägypten haben
dieses Bombardement verurteilt und haben
so zu einer sofortigen Einstellung der
Kämpfe aufgefordert Ägypten spricht von
einer Verletzung des humanitären
Völkerrechts und sagt Israel müsse
sofort aufhören mit seiner Politik der
kollektiven Bestrafung und die Arabische
Liga verurteilt das Bombardement der
Westen solle dieses Elend beenden so
wörtlich also das wirft jetzt noch Öl
auf das ohnehin vorhandene Feuer in der
Region das ist sozusagen der letzte
Tropfen der das fast zum Überlaufen
bringt scheint es die Stimmung hier ist
sehr sehr verhärtet und viele Stimmen
sind hier laut geworden in den
vergangenen Tagen die immer wieder sagen
diese vorbehaltlose Unterstützung des
Westens der israelischen
angriffspolitik das müsse massiv in
Frage gestellt werden und die dem Westen
eben auch Doppelstandards vorwerfen in
Sachen Menschenrechten nun wissen wir
wie gesagt noch nicht wie die
Hintergründe dieses raketeneinschlags in
Gaza sind da sollte man denke ich jetzt
auch noch sehr vorsichtig damit sein
klar ist dass ich die internationalen
Bemühungen auch um eine Grenzöffnung
drehen das haben wir vorhin im Bericht
auch gesehen also dass die Menschen vom
Gazastreifen nach Ägypten können darüber
wird Bundeskanzler Scholz morgen auch in
Ciro sprechen goline was hält Ägypten
eigentlich davon ab Zivilisten und
gegebenenfalls auch Geiseln diese
Ausreise zu
ermöglichen es gibt verschiedene Gründe
der wichtig Grund ist dass der
Sicherheitsapparat hier befürchtet dass
die historische Politik der Vertreibung
der Palästinenser jetzt im Jahre 2023
sozusagen fortgesetzt wird dass also
eine große Zahl von Palästinensern im
ägyptischen Sinai ankommt so wie
Palästinenser vor vielen Jahren im
Libanon angekommen sind in Jordanien
angekommen sind und es wenn sie einmal
hier sind dann Tatsachen geschaffen
werden Fakten geschaffen werden dass
Ägypten keine westlichen
Verhandlungspartner mehr hat um eine
langfristige politische Lösung für diese
Menschen zu finden damit sie
zurückkehren können in ihre Heimat das
ist der gewichtigste Grund es gibt aber
auch noch andere Faktoren die für
Ägypten wichtig sind es fürchtet Chaos
und Gewalt es fürchtet dass auf
ägyptischem Boden durch die Ankunft
dieser Menschen auch eine Art
anti-israelischer
agitationsraum entstehen könnte und das
ist etwas dass die Regierung hier auf
jeden Fall vermeiden möchte die
Einschätzung unserer Korrespondenten in
Tel Aviv und danke euch
beiden die Forderung einen humanitären
Korridor in irgendeiner Form zu schaffen
wird jedenfalls noch dringlicher werden
zugleich würde eine noch weitere
Ausweitung dieses Krieges und auch schon
der Beginn einer Bodenoffensive
natürlich auch die Chancen für eine
Befreiung der Geiseln mindern um die
sich ja viele Regierungen derzeit
bemühen und das liegt ja auch im Kalkül
der Hamas und mit diesem Dilemma und
dieser Angst spielt sie wenn sie jetzt
einzelne Geiseln per Video der
Weltöffentlichkeit vorführt bei seinem
Besuch heute in Israel traf
Bundeskanzler Scholz auch auf Angehörige
die inändig hoffen dass die
internationale Diplomatie irgendetwas
bewegen kann Luk walpot berichtet über
die Reise des
Bundeskanzlers es ist ein Besuch bei
Freunden in schwierigen Zeiten
Deutschland steht an der Seite Israels
das klare Signal nach den gräulen der
Hammers der Kanzler erinnerte im
Gespräch mit Regierungschef Netanyahu
auch an Deutschlands Verantwortung aus
dem Holocaust Israels Sicherheit ist
deutsche staatsresung es ist völlig klar
israel hat das völkerrechtlich
verbriefte Recht sich gegen diesen
Terror zu wehren ein Staat jeder Staat
hat die Pflicht seine Bürger und Bürger
zu schützen Regierungschef Netanyahu
ließ keinen Zweifel an Israels
Entschlossenheit genau wie die Welt
zusammengerückt ist um die Nazis zu
besiegen und den islamischen Staat so
müssen wir jetzt alle gemeinsam mit
Israel die Hamas
besiegen und israel setzt dazu alle
Mittel ein seit einer Woche liegt der
Gazastreifen unter massiven Beschuss die
Opferzahlen steigen die Folgen für die
Zivilbevölkerung dramatisch Diplomaten
versuchen fieberhaft eine noch
tödlichere Kettenreaktion in der Region
zu verhindern US-Außenminister blinken
traf heute Palästinenser Präsident Abbas
morgen wird US-Präsident in Israel
erwartet am Donnerstag reist beiden
weiter nach
Jordanien der Präsident wird von Israel
über die Militäroperation unterrichtet
wie die Zahl ziviler Opfer verringert
werden die Hilfe nach Gaza gelangen kann
ohne dass Hamas sie nutzen
kann der türkische Außenminister war
heute im Libanon Vorbereitungen für
einen Gipfel der am Wochenende in Kairo
stattfinden soll es geht auch darum auf
Iran einzuwirken der Schutzmacht von
Hamas und der libanesischen terrormiliz
die Sorge vor einem Flächenbrand sie
treibt auch Bundeskanzler Scholz um
ausdrücklich war nicht kein Akteur
sollte es für eine gute Idee halten nun
von außen in diesen Konflikt
einzugreifen Irans Führer chamene nannte
unterdessen Israels Angriffe ein
Verbrechen und drohte
seinerseits wenn diese Verbrechen nicht
aufhören wird niemand in der Lage sein
Muslime in aller Welt und die
Widerstandskräfte zu
stoppen über die blutigen grultaten der
Hamas redete chamene nicht diese
Familien deutscher Geiseln in der Hand
der Hamas trafen heute in Tel Aviv mit
Bundeskanzler Scholz zusammen seit einer
Woche bangen sie wie Hanan Kohen dessen
79jährige Schwester Margalit verschleppt
wurde wir wissen dass er morgen nach
Ägypten fährt und wir was wir wissen was
für Einfluss ten hat auf den Terror und
deswegen verlieren wir unsere Hoffnung
nicht es war eine bedrückende Reise für
Bundeskanzler Scholz am Abend geht es
weiter nach
Ciro Theo Koll ist mit dem Bundeskanzler
nach Tel Aviv gereist Theo dieser Besuch
ist natürlich eine auch eine symbolische
Geste der Solidarität aber der
Bundeskanzler wird ja darüber hinaus
auch versuchen etwas diplomatisch zu
erreichen etwa mit Blick auf die Geiseln
gerade die deutschen
Geiseln ja das ist eines der Themen und
der ist gerade im Moment hier in der
Deutschen Botschaft und erklärt
Familienangehörigen den Stand der
Verhandlungen wir sehen hier es sind
Freunde und Familienangehörige kommen
die uns gesagt haben dass sie solange
bleiben wollen und demonstrieren wollen
wie es nötig ist der Hintergrund bei den
Verhandlungen ist offensichtlich so dass
der Kanzler leisen Optimismus äußert er
will es aber nicht öffentlich sagen er
sagt die Telefone laufen heiß und äh das
deutet eigentlich auf Player im Umfeld
er hat sich ja getroffen mit dem emier
von Qatar Qatar ist einerseits Gastgeber
der Spitze von Hamas die dort leben und
zweitens ist es ein Land dass sich auch
in der
afghanistanrise bewährt hat als jemand
mit extrem guten Kontakten zu den
Taliban das Land hat damals geholfen das
Menschen aus Afghanistan rauskommen
konnten also es äh ist kein direkter
diplomatischer Einfluss den Scholz hier
ausüben kann sondern das wird
wahrscheinlich über Bande gespielt
insgesamt ist er aber hier um seine
volle Unterstützung zu zeigen und auch
ein paar andere Themen anzusprechen ja
Stichwort andere Themen der
Bundeskanzler hat ja auch heute noch mal
wieder vor einem Flächenbrand gewarnt
das heißt dass die Bundesregierung nach
wie vor eine Ausweitung des Konflikts
befürchtet ja das ist die unmittelbare
Sorge denn äh ein Flächenbrand könnte
mit Blick auf die mögliche
Bodenoffensive hier äh wirklich
entstehen und deswegen hat er auch in
der Pressekonferenz sogar öffentlich
gesagt Recht und Gesetz müssen gelten
also man versucht hier mit der
israelischen Führung
ähm diese Bodenoffensive so sie denn
stattfindet
ähm so gemäßigt ähm ablaufen zu lassen
dass sie eben nicht zu einer Eskalation
zu einer zwangsläufigen Eskalation führt
denn das ist ja im Grunde das Szenario
dass dann hiszbollah eingreift dass es
viele Opfer gibt im Gazastreifen dass
Iran der ja schon gedroht hat
dann in den Konflikt eingreift also der
der Konflikt hat jedes Potenzial zur
Eskalation zu einem Flächenbrand und den
zu verhindern das versucht Scholz das
wird übrigens auch US-Präsident Joe
Biden hier morgen versuchen die beiden
haben gestern telefoniert sind da
offensichtlich auch auf einer Linie mm
Theo danke erstmal für diese Information
direkt aus
telaviv das Gespräch mit Theo Koll haben
wir am etwas früheren Abend geführt kurz
bevor er mit dem Bundeskanzler nach
Ägypten weiterfliegen sollte diese
Weiterreise wurde aber durch einen
raketenalarm verzögert die ganze
Delegation musste schlagartig das
Flugzeug verlassen und sich erstmal in
Sicherheit bringen bis die israelische
Flugabwehr die Raketen erfolgreich
abschoss israel muss seine
Verteidigungsbereitschaft zeigen gerade
nachdem es am vorletzten Wochenende so
offenkundig nicht abwehrbereit war aber
mit jedem tödlichen Bombardement auf
Gaza mit jedem weiteren militärischen
Schritt steigt die eskalationsgefahr und
bei den Angehörigen von Geiseln steigt
natürlich die Angst auch in Deutschland
bangen Familien um das Leben von
entführten Christ lepple
berichtet das ist Familie
zehn Mitglieder wurden aus einem kibutz
nach Gaza verschleppt darunter vier mit
deutscher Staatsbürgerschaft die
67-Jährige Wissenschaftlerin Schuscha
Haran Gründerin von Fair Planet einer
Hilfsorganisation für Afrika die
38-Jährige Tochter Adi der achtjährige
nave und die dreijährige jahel alle in
der Hand der
Hamas mit allen Familien die ich
spreche
e sie sind voll mit Wut gegen die chamas
aber ich spüre nicht eine kollektive
Hass gegen die Menschen in Gaze ilai
saatzki und Ines Stenger sind Nachkommen
von Holocaust Überlebenden das Berliner
paar kümmert sich bis zur Erschöpfung um
Angehörige der Geißeln mit Z Familien
stehen sie in ständigen Kontakt sie
wollen dass ihre Stimmen in Deutschland
gehört werden
das ist Familie aliev Tochter Karina
absolviert am Morgen des 7 Oktober ihren
Militärdienst am
gaserstreifen die 19-Jährige wird
verletzt und auf einem Pickup in ein
hamasversteck
versteckt Karinas Großeltern haben den
Holocaust überlebt in der Ukraine die
Familie steht unter Schock vor allem der
Großvater so Karinas Schwester
s er war am Boden zerstört er fühlte
sich richtig schlecht er sprach nicht
mehr die einzige Sache die er wissen
wollte war ob sie ihr wenigstens Brot
und Wasser gegeben
haben alle sind verzweifelt aber machen
sich gegenseitig Mut in Berlin und in
Israel sie beteten für die Freilassung
der Geiseln und hoffen auf ein
Wunder ich bin sicher dass meine
Schwester die Stärke unseres Großvaters
hat und ich hoffe sie hat noch mehr
davon als Großvater und meine g Familie
mag sein dass sie allein und ängstlich
ist aber sie wird kämpfen sie gibt nicht
so leicht
auf viele in der jüdischen Community
sind traumatisiert nicht die beiden in
ihrem Berliner Hinterhof sie wollen
etwas tun Gesicht zeigen gegen Hass und
Hetze informieren um weitere
Eskalationen zu verhindern wir kämpfen
wenn wir keine Hoffnung hätten würden
wir halt
weiter
uns machen es gibt kein Happyend auch
wenn Israel das Krieg
gewinnt es gibt keine Gewinner in keinem
Krieg gibt es
Gewinner nur eines kommt nicht in frage
aufgeben das geht nicht für die
beiden zu den vielen Fragen mit Blick
auf diesen Konflikt gehört auch welche
Interessen Russland in der Region
verfolgt in jedem dürfte dieser neue
Nahostkrieg Putin gelegen kommen
US-Präsident Biden hat allerdings gesagt
dass die USA durchaus in der Lage sein
zwei Länder zu unterstützen Israel und
die Ukraine und mit dem Blick in die
Ukraine geht es jetzt bei dir in den
Nachrichten erstmal weiter Heinz herr
Präsident selenski hat heute in seiner
abendlichen videoansprache einen
besonderen Dank an die USA gerichtet
selenski bestätigte die Lieferung
amerikanischer attackems Raketen an sein
Land und deren ersten Einsatz die
attackem haben sich bewehrt sagte er die
Ukraine hatte lange auf die Lieferung
solcher Raketen gedrungen ähnlich wie
auch auf Marschflugkörper vom Typ Taurus
zu denen sich Bundeskanzler Scholz
bislang zurückhaltend geäußert
hat russlandspräsident Putin ist
anlässlich eines internationalen Forums
zur sogenannten neuen Seidenstraße nach
Peking gereist bei dem Gipfel zum
umstrittenen Infrastruktur Projekt der
chinesischen Regierung will Putin auch
persönlich mit China Staatschef hii
sprechen am Rande seines Besuchs traf
sich der russische Präsident zudem mit
Ungarns Regierungschef Orban Putin
sprach von einer Genugtuung dass es noch
Länder in Europa gebe die den Kontakt
mit Russland
hielte in Polen liegt das Endergebnis
der Parlamentswahl vor es bestätigt die
bisherigen Prognosen die bislang
regierende
nationalkonservative Tai peace ist zwar
mit
35,38% stärkste Kraft hat die Mehrheit
im Parlament aber verloren das
liberalkonservative Wahlbündnis
bürgerkoalition von Donald Tusk erhielt
30,7% und will nun mit einem
Dreierbündnis eine neue Regierung
bilden im
usreäsentantenhaus gibt es heute einen
weiteren Versuch einen neuen
Vorsitzenden zu wählen der
republikanische Abgeordnete Jim Jordan
der als Verbündeter von Ex-Präsident
Trump gilt erhielt im ersten Wahlgang
nicht die erforderliche Mehrheit Jordan
gelang es nicht genügend Kritiker in der
eigenen Fraktion für sich zu gewinnen um
Nachfolger des abgewählten Kevin
McCarthy zu werden es wurde mit weiteren
Wahlgängen
gerechnet in den USA ist der
sechsjährige palästinensische junge
beerdigt worden der von einem Amerikaner
erstochen worden war uS-Medien berichten
der Täter habe sich durch den ständigen
Konsum rechtspopulistischer
Radiosendungen radikalisiert die für
ihre Hetze und die Verbreitung von
verschwörungsmüten berüchtigt sind der
Auslöser für das Hassverbrechen sein
dann die Berichte über den Terror der
Hamas gewesen und in Brüssel hat gestern
Abend ein islamistischer Tunesier zwei
Schweden erschossen belgische Ermittler
Berichten der Mann sei auf einschlägigen
Internetseiten unterwegs gewesen auf
denen sich abstruse
verschwörungserzählungen über Schweden
finden und insbesondere aber die
Koranverbrennungen dort angeprangert
werden diese wiederum gehen vor allem
auf das Konto eines in Schweden lebenden
christlichen Irakers der seine
antimuslimischen Aktion damit begründet
dass er in seiner Heimat vom is verfolgt
wurde es kann einem schon schwindelig
werden angesichts der weltweiten
Möglichkeiten Hass zu verbreiten und
neuen zu erzeugen die Anschläge gestern
in Brüssel haben jedenfalls die ganze
Stadt in Atem gehalten gun Krüger
berichtet die Spurensicherung ist da im
Stadteil skabeg wo die Polizei am Morgen
den Mann fasst der die Brüssler eine
Nacht in Atem hielt auch die die seine
Nachbarn
waren ich kenne den Kerl er ging in
dieselbe Moschee wie ich er hatte diesen
Bart einer wie der ich bin erstaunt
es ist das erste Mal dass jemand den ich
kenne so ein Verbrechen
begeht ich finde keine
Worte die Tat ist Terror gestern gegen
19 Uhr ein Mann in roter Jacke schraubt
an seiner Waffe er verletzt einen
Taxifahrer und tötet zwei Fußballfans
die aus Schweden für ein Länderspiel
Spielabbruch als die Nachricht das nahe
Stadion erreicht die Fans müssen bleiben
zu Ihrer Sicherheit denn da ist der
Täter noch auf der Flucht bekennt sich
im Netz zum islamischen Staat betont die
Herkunft seiner Opfer
Schweden am Tag danach die gleichen
Schlüsse in Brüssel und
Stockholm Schweden und schwedische
Interessen so stark bedroht wie jetzt
Gefährder die keine schwedischen
Staatsbürger sind müssen Schweden sofort
verlassen mein erster Schluss ist wenn
jemand ausreisepflichtig ist dann müssen
wir das
durchsetzen so machen Politiker seinen
Fall zum Politikum der mutmliche Täter
soll 45 sein ein Tunesier Asylantrag
abgelehnt aufenilt
sein Mo woh Bilder dieses Sommers da
kickte ein irakischer Christ mit dem
Koran stellte sich drauf zündelte in
Schweden wir müssen das noch genau
untersuchen aber es scheint er hat
gezielt Schweden ausgewählt wegen der
Koranverbrennungen
dort bei der Festnahme am Morgen muss
die Polizei schießen Sanitäter kämpfen
um das Leben ein mutmaßlichen Mörders
ohne Erfolg und die höchste
terrorwahnstufe wird
aufgehoben und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit
anderen Themen des Tages bevor
Bundeskanzler Scholz nach Israel gereist
ist hatte er heute bereits andere
Termine so war er beim arbeitgebertag in
Berlin welche Töne waren da zu hören wer
Haller ja ziemlich kritische die Lage in
den Betrieben sei ernst meint
Arbeitgeberpräsident Dul die Stimmung in
der Breite der Wirtschaft sei gekippt ja
und das bestätigt auch eine vom
Arbeitgeberverband in Auftrag gegebene
aktuelle Umfrage
82% der Unternehmer machen sich Sorgen
um den Standort Deutschland dass die
Bundesregierung keine durchdachte
Strategie zur Bewältigung der aktuellen
Krise hat meinen
88% der befragten Firmen wohl deshalb
steckt da Handeln in dicken Buchstaben
an die Wand geworfen zu viel Bürokratie
hohe Steuerlast Energie teuer die Liste
der Kritikpunkte aus der Wirtschaft ist
lang Kanzler Scholz ging darauf ein und
sagte Unternehmen könnten sich darauf
verlassen dass die Ausbauziele bei den
erneuerbaren Energien 2030 erreicht
würden von einem industriestrompreis
jedoch war nicht die Rede mit Blick auf
die Bürokratie verwies Scholz auf das
bundländertreffen Anfang November da
würden viele Vorschriften angegangen die
Unternehmen schon lange störten der
arbeitgebertag hat gezeigt wie das
Verhältnis zwischen Politik und
Wirtschaft derzeit ist angespannt der
Kanzler versprach zwar mehr Tempo zu
neuen Subventionen aber verliert er kein
Wort seine Antwort auf die Kritik heute
im Großen und Ganzen mutmachchen und
beruhigen Valerie Haller vielen
Dank unter dem Eindruck der Lage in nost
hat kulturstaatsministerin Rot am Abend
die 75 Frankfurter Buchmesse eröffnet
sie vertrat Bundeskanzler Scholz der
wegen der der kurzfristigen Reise nach
Israel seinen Besuch abgesagt hatte die
Angriffe in Israel seinen Angriffe auf
die Menschlichkeit so rot es brauche
mehr denn je Literatur als Quelle der
Empathie Schwerpunktthemen der Buchmesse
sind etwa der Einsatz künstlicher
Intelligenz und der Klimawandel
ehrengastland ist in diesem Jahr
Slowenien für die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft steht auf
ihrer USA Reise heute Nacht unserer Zeit
das zweite Spiel und unter dem neuen
Bundestrainer nagelsmann an nach dem 3:1
gegen Gastgeber USA geht es nun in
Philadelphia gegen das Team aus Mexiko
Philadelphia die Stadt mit den berühmten
72 Stufen auf denen syvester stellone
als Boxer Rocky Ball booher trainierte
nicht weit von der Statue entfernt liegt
die WM-Arena für 2026 in der 50.000
mexikanische Fans erwartet werden das
Team des neuen Nationaltrainers Heime
losano 12 der Weltrangliste ein komplett
anderer Gegner als die usbys sind keine
Mannschaft die so extrem viel zocken
will wie die USA weil insgesamt eine
Mannschaft die leidenschaftlich spielt
lich wie die Zuschauer auch erwartet
werden von mir dass es schon noch mal
ein Tick emotionaler wird aber auch eine
andere Art von Fußball nach dem
gelungenen USA Kick wird es keine große
Rotation geben zu erwarten ist dass
Thomas Müller und Niklas sühle in die
stadrücken gute Einsatzchancen hat auch
Stürmer Kevin Berenz der mit 32 Jahren
vor seinem debü
steht das war's von uns im heute journal
gleich geht es mit der Reportagereihe
37° weiter und um 0 Uhr gibt's dann
unser heute schournal Update mit gundola
Gause und laufend aktuelle Information
haben wir auf ZDF heute und wir beide
melden uns dann morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der hohe Luftdruck
schwindet allmählich und das erkennt man
daran dass wir es mit einem neuen tief
zu tun haben das bringt Regen aus dem
Südwesten zu uns aber nicht nur auch
wärmere Luft erreicht uns und es bildet
sich eine Luftmassengrenze nach nordenin
ist es dann kühler als im Süden in der
kommenden Nacht ist es erst einmal ruhig
und es bildet sich verbreitet Nebel vor
allem aber in der OST Hälfte ganz im
Westen ist es teilweise aufgeklart oder
etwas bewölkt die Temperaturen dazu
sinken auf 0 bis -3° in den
Nebelgebieten milder ist es ganz im
Norden z.B 9° in der Nordsee oder 7° am
oberrein Morgen starten wir dann im
Osten vor allem mit Nebel in den Tag
ganz im Westen scheint häufiger die
Sonne im Südwesten verdichtet sich die
Bewölkung schon mal und zum Nachmittag
beginnt es dort zu regnen ganz im Osten
merken sie nichts da von die sch die
Sonne scheint und das auch im Südosten
also hier Richtung Bayern die höchsten
Temperaturen dabei 12 bis
15° ganz im Westen sind 16° an den Alpen
18° ja und die nächsten Tage gehen sehr
wechselhaft weiter im Norden ist es
meist kühler als im Süden ja 9 bis 21°
dazu gibt's Regen Freitag sogar Sturm
und Samstag können sogar die ersten
Schneeflocken dabei sein einen schönen
Abend